Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're all ones moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not alone.
Capipon champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
Typing Dan's game, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not alone.
Capipon champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
Still here is Bark in the morning, Harry calls me.
His doggy mode reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a time like the feeling of yesterday.
Yeah, yeah, Twitch emotes, Twitch emotes.
Twitch emotes, Twitch emotes.
Wir müssen eh noch uns die volle Kekona-Ladung geben erstmal.
Kappa Porkchamp.
Kappa.
Bible thumb.
What?
Unser, unser, auf der Arbeit, unser Wartungs, äh, Arbeitensystem hat gesagt, ich hätte heute um 21 Uhr Wartungsarbeiten, da muss ich aber kecken.
Davon weiß ich nix.
Und wenn ich da nix von weiß, mach ich heute Abend noch keine Wartungsarbeiten.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Irgendwann ist es ja auch mal gut, ja.
Kek, wait.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz gucken.
was das angeblich für
Warnungsarbeiten sind.
Warte mal. Sack. Sack, Leute.
Nicht, dass ich
irgendwas vergessen habe.
Es ist nicht der Telekom-Kram, Leute.
Der Telekom-Kram ist
fast geschafft.
Aber ich habe erzählt,
ich sollte mit einem Telekom-Techniker zusammen
Ich gucke mal gerade, was das für Dinger sind.
Ich sollte mit einem rein
englischsprachigen Telekom-Techniker
irgendwelche Sachen auf Azure
VMs installieren.
Also mein Part ist easy
gewesen eigentlich.
Der ganze Kram funktioniert nicht, aber das liegt
eher an irgendwelchen komischen Firewalls bei uns
und Telekom
kriegt die Sachen auch nicht hin, aber das hätte ich jetzt
auch nicht anders erwartet. Wobei, der macht
einen Eindruck, als hat er Ahnung.
Ach nee, ich habe
gar keine Wartungsarbeiten.
Irgendjemand hat geschrieben, dass er
Wartungsarbeiten macht.
Das ist ja auch... Was eine bescheuerte
Was eine bescheuerte
Titel von der Mail.
Ja, da steht drin, Ankündigung
Change
21 Uhr und sonst nix.
Und dann steht
Your Activities
steht dann oben drüber.
Your New Activities
steht oben drüber. So.
Da bin ich jetzt von ausgegangen.
Nee, ich mache heute Abend nix,
aber irgendjemand hat in dem Channel einfach nur gepostet.
Er macht was. Mein Gott, Alter, wer
diesen Kram immer konfiguriert, da weiß ich auch nicht mehr weiter.
So.
Auf geht's.
Windows Package Manager. Ja, also.
Ich hatte nämlich vor, ein Video zu machen
über Windows Package Manager und eigentlich
über den, den ich verwende.
Aber wenn wir gerade dabei sind, habe ich gedacht, ich gucke
mir mal WinGet wieder an, ob
WinGet mittlerweile irgendwas
taucht. Das letzte Mal, als
ich WinGet verwendet habe, konnte es keine
Zips und Uninstall
hat teilweise nicht funktioniert.
Ja, Homebrew
ist gut. Homebrew ist aber auch von Leuten gemacht,
die wissen, wie Package Manager geht. Ich bezweifle,
dass Microsoft sowas kann.
Scoop funktioniert
auch gescheit. Choco mag ich nicht so.
Aber das sind zwei unterschiedliche Ansätze.
Das ist ja eher für systemweite Tools und
Scoop ist hauptsächlich für
Sachen, die man in
seinem Heimatverzeichnis installiert. Also
was anderes.
Oh, ich habe neue Sponsoring-
Anfrage. Für was?
Für Cyclic.
Cycle.
Cycle Frontier.
Chat, blickt ihr da durch?
Taugt das was?
Gibt Stonks
massive money.
Oh, und ich habe jetzt eine Antwort. Sekunde, Leute.
Ich weiß, es ist jetzt
richtig dumm. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich nicht vorher
mal in meine Mails geguckt habe.
Ja.
Jetzt muss ich irgendwelche
Mails beantworten hier live im Stream, die ihr nicht
seht. Das ist nicht sonderlich spannend,
aber das dauert nur zwei Minuten, Leute.
Und ich muss meinem
Five Hat Manager
pock, pock,
pock Manager auf Twitter
schreiben, dass er sich das mal anguckt.
Jetzt, na, auch.
So, jetzt bin ich fertig. Alles klar.
Können wir anfangen.
Was ist der Grüne? Ich habe doch schon den Grünen agiler.
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen dem Grün
in Lambo und dem Grünen agiler,
ist doch klar, was ich nehme.
Ne, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, schreibt man im Influencer-Marketing
nicht mehr, Leute. Chat.
Ihr habt keine Ahnung, wovon ihr sprecht.
Anzeige ist raus.
Im Influencer-Marketing ist das alles
viel agiler und moderner.
Da schreibt keiner mehr, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren.
Da schreiben die Leute zum Beispiel
Moin Max
oder Hallo FPS-Fan.
Oh, was?
Hallo FPS-Fan.
Okay, was auch immer man das denn sagen soll.
Ich glaube, da hat sich irgendeiner vertan.
So, alles klar.
Ich mache Browser zu. Auf geht's, Leute.
Gut.
FPS-Teuer.
Ach ja, was macht meine Windows-VM?
Die Windows-VM brauchen wir,
wenn man Windows-Package-Manager ausprobiert.
Vielleicht müssen wir erstmal wieder Windows installieren.
Ne, Windows 11.
Windows 11 ist noch da. Guck mal da.
Oh, what the fuck.
Bestimmt 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, so wie ich mich kenne.
Hä?
Was sonst?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Ähm.
Chat, was meint ihr geht schneller?
Hochfahren und updaten
oder einmal neu installieren?
Ich vermute einmal neu installieren, oder?
Updaten dauert immer.
Okay.
Windows 11 ISO download.
Ja.
Aber die Installation dauert ja auch bloß, keine Ahnung, 5 Minuten oder so.
Es geht ja relativ schnell.
Ja, ISO.
Warum kann man eigentlich Windows 11 ISOs runterladen, aber keine Windows 10 ISOs?
Wo ist, wo ist der Sinn?
Man weiß es nicht.
Ja?
Äh, ich hab nicht so viel Platz.
Guckt mal.
Es ist relativ, es ist relativ eng, Champ, hier, meinem Zeh.
Ja, Windows 11 ist Pains, Champ, ich weiß.
Wir machen jetzt mal kurz den Download, da kann ich euch noch ein bisschen was erzählen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich sollte ja auf der Arbeit mit einem rein englischsprachigen Techniker, äh, Zeug installieren.
Also, gedacht war das folgendermaßen, ähm, also gedacht war das folgendermaßen, ich, äh,
ich, äh, call den Typ oder der call mich und ich share meinen Bildschirm im Teams,
ne, falsch ist die Mode, egal.
Ich share meinen Bildschirm im Teams und der, und der Remote drivet mich dann quasi durch die Installation.
Der sagt mir, wo ich, wo ich klicken muss.
So, soweit, also, was ich klicken muss.
Also, was ich machen muss.
Das ist so ganz abenteu-, abenteuerliches Installationsverfahren gewesen.
Du musstest von denen irgendeine Zip-Datei, äh, äh, ein Skript runterladen, was eigentlich gar kein Skript ist,
sondern ein self-extracting Zip.
Das self-extracting Zip hat sich dann, das ging auch nur unter Ubuntu 20.04, alles andere war nicht supported.
Also, nur, nur das Beste, was man sich so, was man sich so vorstellt.
Und dann hat das Ding, das halbe System vollgeballert.
Das hat alles, ohne Scheiß, das hat alles installiert.
Go, Python, Ruby, äh, Docker, das hat einfach alles installiert, was es gab.
Und sich dann irgendwie gebootet da.
Was auch immer.
Naja, zumindest die Idee war ja eigentlich, ich setze mich mit dem zusammen und mach das.
Und was war es dann am Ende?
Wir waren ein Call mit sieben Leuten.
Ohne Scheiß, sieben Leute.
Es waren drei Leute von uns, drei Leute von der Telekom und ich.
Sieben Leute.
Es haben uns sieben Leute zugeguckt, wie wir da irgendwelche komischen Installer-Commands eingegeben haben.
Ja.
Und irgendwann, irgendwann habe ich den kek-, kek-w-ra-, äh, reißer-
äh, reißer-Joke gebracht während der Installation.
Die fanden alle furchtbar lustig.
Und irgendwann hat die Installation nach einem Passwort gefragt.
Und da habe ich, da habe ich die gefragt, was soll ich denn für ein Passwort nehmen?
Und da haben die gesagt, äh, ja, wissen sie jetzt auch nicht.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, oh, should I face-roll my keyboard?
Und das haben sie alle furchtbar abgefeiert.
Haben sie alle gekekt.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die anderen nicht wissen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die Atmosphäre sonst so mega Painschamp war.
Eigentlich war der Witz mega kacke.
Aber irgendwie fanden sie das lustig.
Und haben alle gemacht lul.
Ultra lul.
So, dann haben wir weitergemacht.
Dann ging's.
Aber am Ende ging's nicht.
Und es geht bis heute nicht.
Also, es war vor zwei Tagen.
Weil, Dinger, keine Ahnung.
Zum Glück, ja, irgendwie schon.
Zum Glück, zum Glück liegt's nicht an mir.
Dass es nicht geht.
So, also, Windows Install CD.
Ach, guck mal.
Wir haben ja schon Windows 10 ISO liegen.
Ne, haben wir nicht.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt haben wir wieder eins da liegen.
Auf geht's, einschalten.
Und schnell, Escape, Escape.
Jawoll, gut, gut.
CD.
Excellent.
Es wird Windows 11 installiert, weil Windows 11 schneller zu installieren ist, als Windows 11 zu updaten.
Und ich brauche ein Windows in der VM, dass ich Package Manager testen kann.
Das geht schnell.
Das dauert fünf Minuten, dann ist das, ist das drauf.
Sieben Leute wurden fürs Zugucken bezahlt.
Korrekt.
Drei Leute bei mir, drei Leute bei der Telekom.
Language to install.
Englisch.
Currency.
Ist mir doch eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Aber ich mach mal, ich mach mal German.
Weil ansonsten kommt da vielleicht noch irgendwie durcheinander.
Next.
Install.
Jawoll.
Was sollte denn installiert werden?
Ich meinte das mit dem Zip.
Ja, wie gesagt, in diesem Zip ist irgendeine Software von der Telekom, die erstmal alles andere nachinstalliert.
Docker, Python, Ruby, Go.
Und sich dann im Docker-Container startet.
Keine Ahnung, was sie da getrieben haben.
Und, ja, was ist das?
Ich weiß gar nicht so genau, was das für eine Software ist.
Es ist irgendwas, was mit Windows Defender zusammenhängt.
Es ist schon, es ist schon wirklich Next Level Bullshit, wenn du dir jetzt mal überlegst.
Wir brauchen eine Software für Windows Defender-Verwaltung, die nur unter Ubuntu 20.04 läuft und von der Telekom programmiert wurde.
Also die Kombination, also mehr Painschamp ist eigentlich nicht möglich.
Es sei denn, es käme von Vodafone oder so.
Das wäre vielleicht noch eine Nummer härter.
Pro installieren wir.
Jawoll.
Windows Defender im Container.
Ne, ne.
Das ist irgendeine Management-Software für Windows.
Nicht für Windows.
Für Windows Defender.
Also für Microsoft Defender.
Irgendeine Management-Software.
Und die läuft nur unter Ubuntu.
Das ist ganz, ganz merkwürdiges Zeug.
Defender-Verwaltung über Azure.
Ähm, fragt mich nicht.
Achso, ja, das machen wir aktuell so.
Defender-Verwaltung über Azure machen wir aktuell so.
Da tauchen manchmal auch in Defender-Logs irgendwelche Passwörter, tauchen da drin auf.
Doch, doch.
Ähm, das machen wir aktuell so.
Aber in Zukunft soll das wohl über dieses Telekom-Ding laufen.
Fragt mich nicht.
Ich habe mir die Software nicht ausgesucht.
Wenn es nach mir geht, wäre auch Windows Defender auch nicht auf allen Kisten drauf.
Also, außer auf Windows.
Bei uns ist es ja mittlerweile so, wir haben ja sogar auf den meisten Linux-Systemen Windows Defender installiert.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, das habe ich nicht entschieden.
Sonst wäre das da nicht drauf.
Ja, hey Smi, so stelle ich mir das auch vor ungefähr.
Wo mal hier Installation flutscht.
Leute, ich habe vorher ein bisschen mein Zabbix weiterkonfiguriert hier daheim, gell.
Das ist...
Das ist einfach nur extremstes Big Brain, was man da teilweise sich ausdenken muss, um den zu überreden, dass der macht, was man will.
Wahnsinn, das müssen wir uns demnächst im Stream auch nochmal weiter angucken.
Ich habe mittlerweile relativ viel drin.
Ich habe die meisten, die meisten Hosts bei mir daheim jetzt im Zabbix drin.
Ich habe mir ein schönes Dashboard gebaut.
Ich überwache sogar meine Internetverbindung.
Ich mache einen Ping auf 1111 und ich mache einen Bandbreiten-Test alle Viertelstunde.
Da habe ich schöne Statistik, wann es Vodafone wieder verkackt.
Sogar nachts.
Nachts ist mir nämlich aufgefallen jetzt.
Ich gucke dann manchmal morgens in meine Monitoring-Probleme.
Da ist mir aufgefallen, dass ganz oft zwischen nachts 3, 3.30 Uhr bis 5 Uhr morgens das Internet nicht funktioniert.
Ich vermute, Vodafone macht in dieser Zeit irgendwelche Warnungsarbeiten.
Öfters mal.
Warum hat das einen Go-Compiler installiert?
Kompliert sich das selber?
Hä?
Vielleicht müssen die irgendwelche Go-Programme kompilieren, nachdem sie von ShitHub geklont haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Was hättest du in dem Unternehmen denn für Linux genommen?
Gar nichts.
Ich hätte gar keine Antiviren-Dings-Lösung für Linux genommen.
Was man machen kann unter Linux ist irgendwelche Audit-Logs.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz sinnig.
Da kann man nachvollziehen, was wie wo gemacht wurde.
Okay.
Aber irgendwelche Threat-Protection hätte ich gar nicht interessiert.
Wozu?
Das Ding macht doch nur Probleme.
Das macht unsinnige CPU-Last manchmal.
Es hat schon dazu geführt, dass wir Server neu starten mussten.
Dreimal am Tag.
Nur wegen Windows Defender.
Und es ist halt, und das muss einem klar sein.
Und das ist jetzt nicht, was ich quasi als Microsoft-Hater übertreibe.
Nein, es ist wirklich so.
Man hat ein Microsoft-Rootkit auf allen Systemen, die Windows Defender haben.
Weil Microsoft kann, also das Ding muss auch immer connectbar sein zu Microsoft.
Und Microsoft kann das Ding hotpatchen.
Microsoft kann nicht nur die Viren-Signaturen und sonstige Sachen hotpatchen.
Nein, die können den Windows Defender hotpatchen.
Und wenn du eine Software quasi patchen kannst, also on the fly, kannst du alles reinpatchen, was du willst.
Das haben wir nämlich daran gemerkt, das sagt Microsoft nicht, aber ich weiß, dass es so ist.
Wir hatten nämlich mal eine Windows Defender-Version aufgespielt aus dem RPM.
Und nach drei, vier Wochen, nachdem das drauf war,
hat das Ding auf einmal ganz merkwürdige Memory-Leaks gehabt, die es vorher nicht hatte.
Und in dem Support-Call, beziehungsweise nicht Support-Call,
mit in dem Support-Ticket von Microsoft hat sich herausgestellt,
ja, das ist ein Fehler, allerdings nicht etwa in der Windows Defender-Version,
die wir aus dem RPM installiert haben, sondern das ist ein Fehler von ihnen,
den sie quasi mit einem Security, ja, was weiß ich, Signatur-Update oder so rausgebracht haben.
So, und wenn du mit einem Signatur-Update es schaffst,
den Windows Defender Memory-Leaks zu verursachen,
dann ist das kein reines Signatur-Update,
dann ist das einfach Hot-Patchen oder Patchen der Software.
Und dementsprechend hast du ein Microsoft-Hootkit auf allen deinen Servern.
Wenn du das in deinem Unternehmen haben willst, schön und gut,
ich meine, ich hätte es nicht installiert, aber da haben sich ja krasse Five-Head-Manager überlegt,
dass das eine gute Idee ist, zu installieren.
Ich hätte es nicht installiert, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Äh, Right Region.
Äh, yes.
Hoffentlich stellt er es mir jetzt nicht auf Deutsch.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, Windows.
Ich habe in der Installation ausgewählt, deutsches Keyboard.
Er fragt mich nach der Region, ich sage Deutsch.
Warum will der mir ein UK-Keyboard?
Warum schlägt der mir ein UK-Keyboard vor?
Wie kann Microsoft nur einfachste Sachen so massiv verkacken?
Und warum kann man ihn hier drinnen nicht suchen?
Nein.
Gleich gibt es vor allem mal Tools-Updates und dann können wir anfangen.
Ja, ja, latest install nervt nicht.
Ja, ja, die ist ein bisschen anders, die IBM-Tastatur ist.
Unter Linux ist es noch mehr.
Unter Linux gibt es fünf verschiedene German-Tastatur-Layouts.
No dead keys, dead things, circumflex fragt mich nicht.
Mit zwei Fingern.
Ich bin froh, wenn die es schaffen, ab und zu mal mit einem Finger zu tippen.
Teilweise habe ich schon hinter Leuten dahinter gestanden und ich dachte mir so, Leute,
drückt das, drückt das, drückt das und der dann so, hm, wo ist es denn, wo ist es denn?
Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, alter, klick unten links, klick unten links, hm, wo ist es, wo muss ich hin?
Ah, hier, hm, nee, da war das nicht, wo war es denn?
Ach ja, und ich denke mir so, das war mir vor 30 Sekunden schon klar, wo du hin willst.
Das ist schlimm, hinter so Leuten zu stehen.
Oh, wel, wel, welcome.
Your device.
YouTube Chat.
Next.
Just a moment.
Es bootet.
Da hast du schon gesehen.
Cloudflare mitigates 26 million requests per second, DDoS.
Ist das, ist das die neueste biggest DDoS attack ever?
Da habe ich letztens ein Video zu gemacht, zu der biggest DDoS attack ever.
Damals war sie aber noch von meiner Seite.
Jetzt war sie aber noch von Microsoft Azure abgewehrt.
Vielleicht sollte, das schreibe ich mir auf, Leute, da mache ich ein neues Video zu.
Das letzte Video ist gut angekommen.
Es gibt so ein paar Videos, die kommen lustigerweise immer gut an.
Immer wenn man was von DDoS in Titel schreibt oder sowas wie, ich wurde gehackt oder solche Dinger, das kommt immer gut an.
Also, set up personal use, auf geht's.
Offline-Account, Mann.
Das ist so hängen geblieben.
Nein, nervt nicht rum.
Max.
Next.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Massive Passwort.
Da kommt nie ein Best-Practice-Passwort.
Jawoll.
Next.
Ach so, ja.
Zwei.
Drei.
Exzellente Questions.
No.
Ah, yes.
Beste Fragen überhaupt.
Bin ich, bin ich froh, dass mich Microsoft das fragt.
Stell dir mal vor, wo kämen wir da hin, wenn die mich das nicht fragen würden?
Da käme ich mir so ungefragt vor.
Okay.
Also, was gibt's neues, Chat, bis sich das eingerichtet hat?
Ja.
Jetzt hast du's geschafft.
Kannst du komplett, kannst du komplett den Hacker, Hackerman starten.
Und dann machst du, dann toppst du den 26 Millionen Requests Cloudflare DDoS Angriff.
Ich hab, warum soll ich hochscrollen?
Ich hab das schon gesehen.
Da wollte ich grad was zu sagen.
Ich kann das nicht alles im Erhalt von 15 Sekunden beantworten, was ihr im Chat schreibt.
So einfach ist das nicht.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Dann wäre ja WinUI 3 schon fertig und würde funktionieren für alles.
Ja, der hängt 30 Minuten hintendran im Chat.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Erstmal 30 Minuten im Chat hintendran.
So.
Was hat er geschrieben?
Genau das hier hab ich gesehen.
Lili Kai hat die Zusage als Azubi bekommen.
Zusage als Azubi bekommen für Feezy.
Wer das nicht mitbekommen hat, er oder sie, ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher
bei dem Namen, war letztens im Chat, mehrfach im Chat und hat von Bewerbungsversuchen erzählt
und hat sich hier Rat vom Huge High IQ Chat geholt.
Und anscheinend sieht man zwar wieder, wo bloß auf Twitch gucken und High IQ Chat haben
und sich helfen lassen.
Ist eine sinnvolle Sache, weil hier hat es funktioniert und schön, dass es funktioniert
hat.
Wann geht es denn los?
1.8.
Oh, das ist ja nur noch einen Monat hin.
Chat Plays Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ey, stellt euch mal vor, das wäre der Renner, oder?
Ich meine, es gab Chat Plays Pokémon, Chat Plays, ne, Fisch Plays Pokémon.
Warum sollte man nicht Chat Plays Vorstellungsgespräch machen?
Du teilst einfach den Bildschirm so in vier Bereiche ein und der Chat spammt dann ganz
viel 1, 2, 3, 4 und je nachdem, also wir machen das natürlich aus Einstellersicht, und je
nachdem, was der Chat auswählt, wird der Kandidat gefragt.
Das wäre doch was.
Ja, aber 1.8. ist wirklich noch mal lange hin.
Ja, das ist ja quasi, sagen wir mal, ein Monat.
Ja, dann ruhe ich jetzt noch mal ein bisschen aus.
Weil dann geht es los.
Haben die dir schon gesagt...
Ach Quatsch, kein Monat noch.
Ja, doch, ein Monat, sage ich doch.
Haben die dir schon gesagt...
Ja, skippen...
Man skippt am...
Skippt man am Ende?
Wartet mal, Leute.
Ich bin gerade...
Ja, ja, man skippt am Ende, ne?
Man macht die Prüfung früher, man skippt nicht den Anfang.
Ja, ja, man skippt am Ende.
Also ich...
Ich kann das nicht empfehlen.
Ich kann das nicht empfehlen, das zu skippen.
Ich hatte auch damals die...
Also theoretisch die Option, wenn ich gewollt hätte.
Ich wollte aber nicht.
Erstens wollte ich noch eine Runde faul in der Berufsschule sein.
Weil die Berufsschule ist quasi wie Urlaub gewesen.
Und zweitens fand ich es nicht schlecht, dass man noch ein bisschen was lernen kann, ohne dass man dafür verantwortlich ist.
Weil das muss einem immer klar sein.
Wenn man denn fertig ist, dann bist du im Endeffekt für das, was du machst, dann auch verantwortlich.
Das ist einem als Azubi nicht so klar.
Also da ist eigentlich egal, was man macht.
Aber wenn du später verkackst, dann musst du in der Regel auch dann das ausbaden.
Ja, hört sich jetzt schlimmer an, als es ist.
Also ich habe schon ein paar Sachen verkackt und es ist nie großartig, was passiert.
Das hilft, das wird dir auf jeden Fall helfen.
Dann machst du...
Dann kannst du die Berufsschule 1er und 2er schreiben, ohne dass du irgendwas machen musst.
Höchstwahrscheinlich.
Ja, also dann kannst du Berufsschule face rollen.
AfK.
Ach ja, und guck dir mal genau die Regelung an, wie das ist, ab wieviel Stunden Berufsschule du noch auf die Arbeit musst und ab wieviel nicht.
Ich hatte das damals instant nachgeguckt und war im Prinzip nach der Berufsschule nie mehr auf der Arbeit.
Aber wir hatten in der Schule Leute, die haben es bis zum Ende nicht gecheckt und sind dann teilweise noch nach 6 Stunden oder so auf die Arbeit.
Was man damals gar nicht musste.
So, was ist denn hier los?
Warum ist das so klein?
Weil VMware Tools nicht installiert ist.
Ja.
Bei VMware Tools.
Geh wem.
Sollte jetzt nicht eigentlich.
Ah, hat nur, hat nur ewig gedauert.
Yes.
Ach, du hast doch nicht unterschrieben?
Dann würde ich das möglichst, möglichst schnell in trockene Tücher bringen.
Bei mir hat es auch keinen.
Wir testen heute...
Also was wir heute testen ist folgendes.
Gut, Scoop muss ich eigentlich nicht testen, den zeige ich euch nochmal.
Weil das ist der auch, den ich empfehlen würde.
empfehlen würde.
Schoko testen wir oder Schokoladier.
Wie auch immer.
Poggers,
Frenchwörter.
Und wir testen Wingert.
Vor allem Wingert.
Ich habe ein uraltes Bild.
Wie?
Wie, ich habe ein uraltes Bild? Ich habe das gerade von der Microsoft-Seite
heruntergeladen.
Oder was meinst du? Hä?
Was für ein altes Bild?
Das ist
das ISO, was ich gerade
von Microsoft heruntergeladen habe.
Hier, guckt.
Downloads.
ISO.
Was da?
Ernsthaft?
Wie?
Also Microsoft könnte echt mal so ein Wettbewerb
machen. Wie kacke wollt ihr sein?
Und daran nehmen dann teil, die Telekom,
Vodafone, die Bahn,
Microsoft.
Und dann machen sie einen Wettbewerb.
Wer schafft es schlechter zu sein?
Gut, ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, wer gewinnt.
Äh, SAP.
Es gibt so viele Schrottsoftware, Leute.
Was macht eigentlich Drextool aktuell?
Sekunde, das muss ich mir mal kurz angucken.
Die Seite, die Seite...
Die Seite habe ich früher gefeiert.
Die wird, glaube ich, nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Man sieht, die Seite sieht auch schon aus wie sonst was.
Drextool. Also.
Der Citrix ICA-Client
ist auf Platz 1.
Lotus Notes auf Platz 2. Das hat es auch verdient.
Teams ist relativ weit oben.
Bestes Design, oder?
Ernsthaft? Okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt
eh nochmal updaten, oder was?
Ach, man.
Microsoft.
Blitz.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das...
Das muss man sich echt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Du lädst dir das ISO von der aktuellen
Seite runter, aber nein,
es ist nicht aktuell.
Die...
Was soll ich mir runterladen? MSU?
Das ist...
Das ist aber nur ein ISO, was ich nochmal installieren muss.
Nee, nochmal installiere ich jetzt nicht.
Öffne mal den Store.
Sieht so kacke aus wie immer.
Als wenn die jeden Monat eine neue ISO bauen.
Hey, soll ich dir mal was sagen?
Die meisten Linux-Distributionen bauen ihre ISOs
daily. Wenn du dir...
Wenn du dir ein Raspbian runterlädst, zum Beispiel.
Sorry, Raspberry Pi OS ist es jetzt, ja.
Ist das einfach immer
tagesaktuell. Ubuntu auch?
Hängt sich die App-Seite...
...in den Settings.
Nö.
Download now. Ja, mach.
Auf.
Gib alles.
Warum ist der Bild so alt, man?
Ich hab das ISO eben runtergeladen.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Raspberry Pi OS ist...
Okay, wenn es nicht daily ist, ist es weekly.
Das ist ziemlich aktuell.
Also Ubuntu ist auf jeden Fall, das weiß ich.
Hattest du schon mal E-Mail-Stürme?
Nee.
So, jetzt timen wir mal, wie lange das dauert.
So, wir haben jetzt 20 Uhr.
Warum hat es mich nochmal gefragt,
ob ich in Germany bin?
Um dann die Sommerzeit nicht richtig einzustellen.
Mann, Microsoft.
Wie kann man so ein Dreck rausbringen, Alter?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich hab gesagt, Germany.
Ich hab gesagt, German Key Layout.
Ich hab gesagt, bei der Installation
German Key Layout. Germany Region.
Warum ist da jetzt die Zeit falsch?
Add-In-Block.
Dublin.
Äh.
Ähm.
Chat, wo sind wir?
Berlin suche ich hier irgendwo.
Sind wir nicht bloß zwei?
Wo sind wir denn?
Es gibt kein Amsterdam Berlin.
Amsterdam.
Wir sind bloß eins?
Sind wir nicht bloß zwei gerade?
Sind wir nicht gerade bloß zwei in der Sommerzeit?
Ich check's.
Man muss es nicht verstehen.
Der Schalter ist grau.
Warum auch immer.
Man weiß es nicht.
So, wie sieht's jetzt mit Updates aus?
Haben wir es jetzt irgendwann geschafft?
Immer das Update.
Ja, oh Gott.
Jetzt muss ich drei Stunden warten, Mann.
Ich hasse Microsoft-Krams in der Richtung.
Microsoft macht ja durchaus gutes Zeug, ja?
Visual Studio Code ist wunderbar.
Die ganze .NET C-Sharp-Entwicklung ist wunderbar.
Was sie mit GitHub machen, ist zum größten Teil auch okay.
Aber was sie mit GitHub machen, ist zum größten Teil auch okay.
Aber was sie mit Windows veranstalten, ist wirklich unter aller Sau.
Du musst dieses...
Also, du möchtest dieses Betriebssystem wirklich nicht verwenden.
Du willst eigentlich was anderes verwenden, aber du kannst in vielen Fällen nicht.
Also, Windows verkauft sich nicht, weil Windows punkten könnte.
Windows verkauft sich einzig und allein dadurch, dass man mit den anderen...
Sag mal.
Auf.
Download.
5%.
Weißt du was, Leute?
Ich starte.
Ich starte jetzt neu, weil ich wette mit euch, das hat es wieder aufgehängt.
Wir testen WinGet zuerst.
Wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht, ja.
Mal gucken.
Erstmal brauche ich ein Windows, auf dem ich was überhaupt testen kann.
Please, Microsoft.
Ich habe nur maximal 2 Stunden Zeit.
Ich dachte, das ist kein großes Ding.
Was ist noch vor allem?
Okay, jetzt.
Update.
Failed.
Weird Champ.
Auf.
Ja, mach.
Microsoft.
Komm.
Wie teuer waren deine Server?
Was genau willst du wissen?
Auf was bezieht sich das?
Welche?
Also, ich habe mir schon überlegt, was wir machen.
Also, wir lesen uns jetzt erstmal nebenbei.
Wir gucken mal schnell in diesen Cloudflare-DDoS.
Deine Heiminfrastruktur.
Ach, das geht eigentlich.
Also, wenn du jetzt nur das Aktuelle nimmst.
Also, ich habe aktuell den letzten Generation HP Micro.
Der hat irgendwie, glaube ich, 800 Euro oder so gekostet.
Einen Gigabit.
Also, machen wir doch mal ganz schnell.
Ich brauche das andere Video.
Das unaufgeräumte Video brauche ich.
Ne, das ist das richtige Video.
Das ist das.
Ja, also.
Also, hier sieht man doch schon ein paar was.
Also, das da unten ist alles wurscht.
Also, was habe ich da von im Einsatz?
Die Fritzbox habe ich.
Das ist die billigste Fritzbox, die es gibt mit 100 MBit.
Hat irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 80 Euro gekostet oder so.
So, da oben.
Das habe ich gar nicht im Einsatz.
Da oben steht mein Router.
Der hat auch irgendwie 70 Euro gekostet.
So, ich, warte mal.
Ich warte mal kurz, bis ich das zeige.
Ja, die Kiste habe ich nicht mehr im Einsatz.
Also.
Switch.
500 Euro ungefähr.
10 Gigabit.
12 Ports.
SF4 Plus.
10 Gigabit.
Und 4 Ports.
10 Gigabit Kupfer.
Oh, der Rest ist nicht der Rede.
Wer?
Irgendwelche Stromleisten und sowas.
Wurscht.
Ja, hier der Server unten.
Es war Eigenbau mit 10 Gigabit Karte.
Nicht so teuer.
Aber den habe ich jetzt durch diesen 800 Euro HP-Microsoft ersetzt.
Und die USV, die ist kaputt.
Das war's.
Mehr gibt es hier nennenswert nicht zu sehen.
Die Wera-Tools insgesamt waren wahrscheinlich teurer, ja.
Sag mal.
Mensch, Microsoft.
Ich fasse es nicht, Alter.
Okay.
Wir können eigentlich, können wir denn überhaupt schon anfangen so, weil ich denke, ist das
jetzt der neue Windows Store oder ist es noch der alte?
Ja, was soll ich denn machen, wenn das nicht downloadet?
Versucht mal, einen Exchange Server zu patchen.
Auch immer ist fertig.
Bam.
Null auf 100 Prozent.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die mache ich nicht.
Und eine Sache davon ist Exchange Server patchen.
Also es ist ja bei uns auf der Arbeit bisschen Umstrukturierung demnächst.
Und wir bekommen zwei Windows Leute mit ins Team.
Habe ich gehört, habe ich gehört.
Aktuell sind wir ja hauptsächlich, also was heißt hauptsächlich?
Bis auf, bis auf einen Zytrix, Zytrix, Sidetricks, Sidetricks, Mann.
Sind wir alles Linux Leute.
Und jetzt bekommen wir zwei Windows Leute ins Team.
Ein Admin-Grill, Leute, habe ich gehört.
Poggers.
So, also wir bekommen zwei Windows, zwei Windows Leute.
Und.
Sollte irgendjemand wirklich auf die Idee kommen und zu mir sagen, Max, einer dieser Windows Leute braucht im Thema XY ein Backup.
Und dieses Thema hat auch nur entfernt, also Backup ist gemeint, wenn er mal in Urlaub muss, dass einer ein bisschen Ahnung noch hat.
Und sollte dieses Thema, was ich backuppen soll, nur entfernt was mit Linux zu tun haben, dann mache ich das nicht.
Äh, mit Windows zu tun haben.
Nicht mit Linux.
Mit Windows zu tun haben, dann mache ich das nicht.
Ich werde, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt zwei Sachen.
Die für mich Gründe, Gründe zum Kündigen wären.
Das ist, es gibt kein Homeoffice mehr.
Und das ist, ich soll Windows administrieren.
Ansonsten.
Eigentlich nicht so viel.
Aber diese zwei Sachen.
Homeoffice abschaffen oder Windows installieren.
Äh, Windows administrieren.
Wie wohnst du?
Wohnung, Haus, Haus.
Gekauft, geerbt.
Bauen würde ich das nicht.
Vor allem mit meinen Stonks, die so gefallen sind.
Könnte ich jetzt das auch gar nicht.
Bauen.
Wobei, ich habe ja bei weitem nicht alles in Stock.
Es gibt tatsächlich Menschen, die das sogar richtig gerne haben mit Windows Server.
Es gibt, es gibt sogar Leute, die gerne Windows Server als VMs administrieren, habe ich gehört.
Was macht dir besonders Spaß an deinem Job?
IT Security und von welchen Dingen stören dich am meisten nicht bezogen auf den Arbeitgeber, sondern auf die Branche?
Boah, da müsste ich jetzt mal überlegen.
Ähm, also ich sage jetzt mal was ganz Allgemeines, was mich nervt, ist, äh.
Managern im Allgemeinen, die realitätsferne Sachen entscheiden.
Okay, wir sind schon bei 34%, Leute, es geht aufwärts.
Ja, das ist branchenweit, das ist, das ist branchenweit.
Kein, es gibt es überall.
So höre ich ja auch hier auch öfters im Chat.
Und wisst ihr, was ich besonders witzig finde?
Die ganzen Manager, die sagen, ha, ich finde Elon Musk so geil.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sie, dass sie gerne Elon Musk wären.
Aber halt, es nicht können.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich sagen würde, ja, ich wäre gerne, ähm, boah, keine Ahnung.
Wer fällt euch im IT-Sektor ein, der richtig massive, äh, äh, Dings hier?
Der, der PS, der PlayStation-Hackerman, ähm, wie heißt er?
Ja, GeoHot, wie heißt er?
Georg irgendwas, Georg.
Streamt auch manchmal, Georg Hotz, genau.
Ja, das, das, das, ich kann viel sagen, der, der Tag, was ich gerne können würde.
Aber nur, nur weil ich das sage, das heißt es nicht, dass ich das irgendwie auf die Reihe kriege.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie die ganzen Designer, die sagen, ich wäre gern Steve Jobs oder so, mein Vorbild ist Steve Jobs.
Aber dann schon, also wisst ihr, die Leute, die bei Microsoft arbeiten und den Windows Store designt haben, da gibt es bestimmt auch ein paar von, die sagen,
ihr großes Vorbild ist Steve Jobs.
Und, genau, und, und, man fällt schon im Ansatz.
Warum gibt es eigentlich ein Update da und da?
Ich meine, das ist ja schön und gut, wenn man Vorbilder hat.
Aber im Manager-Bereich ist es ja so, die sagen ja nicht nur, ihr Vorbild ist Elon Musk, die tun immer so, als wären sie der deutsche Elon Musk.
Sind es halt nicht.
Ey, ein Vorbild zu haben ist ja kein Problem.
Ist ja gut, das sollen sie machen, ja.
Wie viel Homeoffice machst du?
Ich arbeite vier Tage, drei Tage Homeoffice, einen Tag vor Ort.
Ja, mache ich auch nicht, Windows wird nicht mehr supportet.
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Nur, nur ETF-Stongs.
Aber die sind halt, weil alle Stongs schlecht sind, auch schlecht.
Wundert mich nicht, bei Windows ist das oftmals auch nicht so nachvollziehbar.
Ja, wisst ihr, bei Managern ist das teilweise wirklich so.
Du denkst ja so, sie denken, sie sind der deutsche Elon Musk.
Sind aber weder Chef noch sonst was, sind halt so irgendwie vielleicht auf Abteilungsleiter-Ebene oder noch sowas oben drüber, keine Ahnung.
Können eigentlich überhaupt nichts bestimmen in der Tragweite, wie das Elon Musk könnte.
Und die Firma drumherum passt halt überhaupt nicht dazu.
Und dementsprechend ist das, was gemacht wird, halt ein Elon Musk auf Wish bestellt quasi.
Haben wir es jetzt mit 69 installt, alles klar.
Hat es jetzt geup...
Oh, guck mal, ich habe den neuen Windows Store.
Hä?
Ist das der neue Windows Store?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der Update-Button im neuen Windows Store ist.
Leute, wo ist der Update-Button im Windows...
Ach hier, hier ist der jetzt.
Okay, get updates.
Und das andere ist immer noch bei 69.
Leute, es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir eine Stunde brauchen.
Die Windows-Installation hat fünf Minuten gedauert, dass wir eine Stunde brauchen, bis der mit dem ganzen Update-Shit durch ist.
Kann doch nicht...
Das war bei 1969.
Das war bei Windows 95 so, 98 so.
Ich dachte, im Jahr 2022 sind wir da irgendwann mal drüber raus.
Wo sehe ich eigentlich mein Windows-Bild?
CMD.
Winfair ist es, gell?
Winfair.
So, ich habe 21H2.
Bild 22200818.
Und wo sieht man jetzt, ob das neu oder alt ist?
Okay, erstmal Chrome runterladen.
Ach Gott, geh weg!
Ah!
Äh!
Leute!
Ah!
Wo geht das zu?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich anklicke.
Don't allow auf jeden Fall.
Chrome.
Okay.
Ich will nicht den deutschen.
Ich will den internationalen Chrome.
Jawohl.
Wunderbar.
Microsoft, was ist denn hier los?
Ich...
Also...
MonkaS.
Okay, Chrome ist anscheinend am Start.
Wunderbar.
Drei Mal habe ich es jetzt runtergeladen.
On your Murks.
Düdüdüdüdüdü.
Was genau macht es eigentlich im Hintergrund,
wenn es dann fünf Minuten auf 69% steht?
Äh, passt schon.
Also, äh, Adblock.
Nee, ähm, U-Block Origin.
Das muss sein.
Anders funktioniert das nicht.
U-Block Origin.
Leute, ich glaube, das liegt an meinen VM-Tools,
dass das...
dass das Overlay nicht richtig funktioniert.
Kommt der Internet-Explorer noch, ja?
Äh, was?
Nee.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh, hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Warum Google Chrome und Firefox?
Nein, ich will mich nicht anmelden.
Okay.
Wunderbar.
Also, was wir jetzt ausprobieren, ist Winged.
Und wir probieren dann...
Das mag...
Das mochte ich das letzte Mal überhaupt nicht.
Was ich...
Also, mein Lieblings-Package-Manager ist Scoop.
Eindeutig.
Der hat auch die größten Auswahl und alles.
Aber wir probieren...
Wir probieren Winged.
Oh, es ist vorinstalliert, tatsächlich.
Was ist hier los?
Chrome-Setup.
Alter, nein.
Ich hab's doch schon längst installiert, Mensch.
Ich krieg wirklich immer die Krise, wenn ich den Shit hier sehe.
Oh, 82%, Leute.
Die kumulativ-Updates.
Windows und Package-Manager.
Ja.
Also, ich will jetzt noch warten, bis das fertig ist mit dem Update.
Einfach, dass es aktuell ist.
Ey, guckst du Montana Black?
Nee.
Was hältst du von ihm?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne ihn nicht wirklich.
Wir kennen uns ganz kurz flüchtig von der Gamescom.
Aber nur...
Wirklich nur kurz.
Wir haben irgendwie zwei, drei Jahre mal kurz getroffen.
So in den Call-of-Duty-Zeiten noch.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich hab mir dann wirklich auch nie eine Meinung großartig drüber gebildet.
Guck ich nicht.
Ey, man kriegt so ein paar Sachen mit.
Man kriegt so ein paar Sachen mit.
So irgendwie diese Rolex-Geschichte oder so, was da mal war.
Und sonst war es, dass alle sagen, irgendwie ultra abgehoben.
Keine Ahnung.
Interessiert mich auch nicht.
Was ich teilweise ein bisschen merkwürdig finde.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht Montana Black bezogen, sondern allgemein größere Streamer bezogen.
Gerade in Deutschland habe ich den Eindruck, ich verstehe nicht, dass teilweise zwölfjährige Leute ihr Taschengeld donaten.
Ähm.
An Multimillionäre.
Ich meine, das könnte man besser einsetzen.
Ihr könntet auch einfach ein Prime-Abo bei mir abschließen oder so.
Also das verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Ansonsten, jeder soll supporten, was er mag.
Aber gerade, dass so viele...
...doch schon sehr junge Leute da ihr Gramm donaten.
Kann ich nicht irgendwie...
Ist aber im englischen Bereich auch so.
Wenn man sich die ganzen Top-Let's-Player da anguckt und Streamer, das ist so...
Ah, ich verstehe es nicht.
Dann sollen sie lieber das behalten und sich was für sich, was ordentliches, kaufen.
Was sind Packages? Packages sind einfach ganz normale Windows-Programme.
Marvelous Marshmallow.
Danke für den Prime-Stream.
Danke für den Prime-Sub.
Siehst du, dieses Abo-Falle zieht.
Ich dachte...
Da war jetzt keine Zeit für.
Der hat 10 Minuten installiert.
Da kann man nicht erwarten, dass der einfach rebootet und dann geht das.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. So einfach ist das nicht.
Der muss jetzt erstmal nochmal installieren.
Äh, Stufmann, danke schön für den Sub.
Ailo, Polka-Subscriptions. Danke, Leute.
Also, wenn ihr mit eurem Geld wirklich was Gutes tun wollt.
Donatet es nicht Streamern.
Auch nicht mir.
Oder YouTubern. Auch nicht mir.
Sondern guckt mal zum Beispiel, wie es bei eurem lokalen Tierheim aussieht.
Ob die irgendwie Futter brauchen, ob die irgendwelches Equipment brauchen.
Oder im Zweifelsfall einfach nur, ob die irgendwie Paypal zum Spenden haben.
Und sie es nötig haben.
Und sie haben es wahrscheinlich nötig.
Also, ich persönlich, ich spende öfters mal was.
Sowohl für unser Tierheim vor Ort, als auch...
Ich hab so ein paar Dinger, wo ich halt öfters mal...
Katzenhilfe Karlsruhe, witzigerweise, die hab ich auf Twitter gefunden damals.
Und die hatten irgendwie auf ihrer Seite was, wo es drum ging.
Irgendwie...
Ach, meine letzte Katze.
OP-Spenden hab ich damals was gespendet.
Den spende ich auch ab und zu immer mal wieder was.
Und da weiß man, da ist das Geld auf jeden Fall gut aufgehoben.
Und...
Ja, bevor ich das für Menschen spende, spende ich es lieber fürs Tierheim.
Ja, an Open-Source-Projekte kann man das auch machen, wenn man will.
Natürlich, letztendlich muss jeder selbst überlegen, was er will.
Ja.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl hab, und ich sag...
Ich.
Ich sag nicht, dass ihr das so machen sollt, weil...
Eigentlich ist es ein bisschen asozial, aber gut, was willst du machen?
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl hab...
Spende für arme Kinder in Afrika.
Oder spende für die Katzenhilfe.
Oder für lokales Tierheim, da spende ich immer fürs Tierheim.
Mich juckt das Elend im lokalen Tierheim deutlich mehr, als das Elend von Kindern in Afrika.
Klingt jetzt fies, ich weiß, aber...
Ich sag ja auch nicht, dass ihr das machen sollt.
Und man kann mit meinem Geld halt machen, was ich will.
Und ich spende hauptsächlich für...
Wenn ich spende, für Tierheime und sonstige Sachen.
Nicht für Menschen.
Menschen kriegen kein Geld von mir.
Man kann's auch...
Man kann machen, was man will.
Wie gesagt, das muss jeder selbst wissen, was ihm da am Herz liegt.
Bei mir liegt mir deutlich mehr das Tierheim und das Elend der Tiere dort am Herzen, als Kinder in Afrika.
Aber soll jeder machen, was er will.
So, haben wir's jetzt eigentlich geschafft mit Updates?
Ne, warte mal.
Wo ist der...
Was ist denn das für ein Shit?
Oh ne, das ist dieses Widget-Ding.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, Widgets...
Piss dich, Aldo!
Settings, okay, ich hoffe, wir haben geupdatet.
Jawoll!
You're up to date!
Hoho!
PostChamp, sind wir wirklich up to date?
Wirklich, Microsoft?
Wirklich?
Was checkt der da eigentlich so lang?
Das ist eine JSON-Response mit 100 Kilobyte oder so.
Warum dauert denn das so lang?
Das ist ein JSON-Response-File mit einem Kilobyte drinne.
Warum braucht das so lang?
Oh, das ist XML.
Das ist Microsoft, Microsoft mag XML.
Tinnity, danke für den Sub.
Ah, du hast jetzt den Goldkeks.
Pock.
Ist das jetzt quasi randomized wie Lootboxen, oder?
Gibt es einen Grund, dass man an Microsoft zurückgeht?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Microsoft so etwas nicht in eine Domain einbinden kann.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil es Microsoft und Windows...
Ach, jetzt sind wir doch aktuell.
Hä?
Eben hat er doch gesagt...
Na, was auch immer.
Okay, Leute.
Also.
Legen wir mal los.
Ach Gott, das ist ja...
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal.
Nicht nur, dass sie den Windows-Button da nicht hinmachen.
Nein, an der Stelle ist jetzt ein anderer Button, wo der Windows-Button vorher war.
Wie bekomme ich denn dieses Widget-Ding weg?
Das brauche ich nicht.
Widgets.
Weg.
Chat.
Search.
Weg.
Kann man...
Kann man das wieder so einstellen mittlerweile?
Dass das...
Dass das links ist, der Button?
Ist das...
Ist das möglich?
Oder geht das immer noch nicht?
Geht?
Behaviour.
Aha.
Left.
Boah.
Schau Badges.
Unread Message Counter.
Braucht kein Mensch.
Share any Window from my Taskbar.
Das sind Optionen, die ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Ja.
Also.
So.
Ne la pas de die Welt nicht braucht.
Was soll das bedeuten?
Share any Window from my Taskbar.
Nein, das ist so assistants erklärend.
Wir brauch nämlich mal ein Hilfe-Button oder so, was es bedeutet.
Ich mein, ordentliches UID-Design hätte ja ein Hilfe-Button, wo ich drüberklicken kann
oder auch hoffern, das sagt mir, was es ist.
Das ist aber halt nicht So.
Machen wir mal aus.
So.
Auf gehts.
Ekliges CMD.
Das erste, was wir installieren mit Winget ist Ach so.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Da war die Qt4M.
Erste Mal mal mein Snapshot.
Wieso ist das eigentlich Englisch?
Weil ich englische Sprache und deutsches Tastatur-Layout habe.
Genauso wie ich das hier auf meinem Host habe.
Ich kann es übrigens auch nur jedem empfehlen, Windows auf Englisch zu stellen,
weil wenn ihr irgendwann mal nach Fehlermeldungen suchen müsst
oder nach irgendwelchen Problemen googeln müsst,
ist das einfach um Welten einfacher, die englischen Texte zu googeln,
als die Microsoft Translation.
Also, WinGet. Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Also, ich zoome mal etwas ran, dass ihr was seht.
Hä? Was war das?
Äh. Aha.
Also, was kann man hier machen?
Install, Show, Sources, okay, Search, List, Upgrade, okay.
Probieren wir mal. WinGet, Search, Search Terminal.
Was?
Ja, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Search Terminal.
Auf Fullscreen.
Windows Terminal Preview.
Ist es das?
Microsoft Windows Terminal Preview.
Warum ist das Preview?
Ist das immer Preview?
Es gibt ja auch Windows Terminal.
Ach, Terminal ist schon drauf mittlerweile.
Oh.
Poggers, Alter.
Ja.
Windows Terminal Applikation, please.
Windows Terminal.
Save.
Default Profile PowerShell, ja, meinetwegen.
Hä?
Was tut es?
Schließt sich das nicht, wenn man auf Save klickt?
Ach, das safet einfach und ich muss es dann so schließen.
Mein Gott.
Es muss erst mal einer durchblicken, ja.
Also, alles klar.
Okay.
Ich habe mir ein paar Dinger notiert, die ich überprüfen möchte, ob sie da sind.
Nämlich Sachen, die ihr auch aktuell bei mir über Scoop installiert habt.
Das erste, wir fangen mal mit sinnvollen Sachen ein.
Seven-Zip.
Okay, Seven-Zip gibt es.
Was jetzt noch interessant wäre, wenn man nachgucken könnte, wo...
Also, ich möchte mir gerne...
Das Install-Skript oder die Install-Uhr angucken.
Weil, vielleicht ist ja da auch irgendwas dabei, was sich eingeschlichen hat.
Kann man irgendwie Details oder sowas machen?
Also, Search, List, Show.
Show, Seven-Zip.
Na geil, das bringt mir jetzt auch nicht wirklich was.
LibreOffice, sowas installiere ich nicht.
Aber kann ich zu eurer Erheiterung machen.
Also, Show mit der ID.
Also, so.
Ich meine, Obvious, das muss man doppelt schreiben.
Klar, was sonst?
Ja, das mag ich.
Das finde ich gut.
Ja, Moment.
Das sind die Meta-In...
Ach, hier, das meine ich.
Download-Uhr.
Das ist immer ganz interessant, nochmal zu gucken.
Ey, WinGet mit Windows 10 kannst du nachinstallieren, ja?
Also, WinGet, Install.
Und jetzt wahrscheinlich Seven-Zip, Seven-Zip, vermute ich einfach mal.
Aber es ist schon...
Äh, kann ich das nicht?
Moment, ich brech das mal ab.
Ich möchte, dass er das lokal installiert.
Kann das WinGet?
Was?
Wow, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Ähm, kann das installieren im Heimatverzeichnis?
Location.
Ähm...
Da muss ich mal kurz googeln.
Oh Gott, das geht ja immer noch nicht.
Äh, WinGet, Install, Home Directory.
Ne, lokal ist die Sprache.
Auto install...
Minus, minus, Location.
Ja, das ist aber...
Auf dem Host?
Ne, das müll ich mir mit dem Kram nicht zu.
Was, minus I?
Wie kann man machen?
Minus I macht was?
Interactive.
Request Interactive Installation.
Ne, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Okay, also WinGet ist anscheinend nicht darauf ausgelegt, dass irgendwie lokal...
Minus, minus Scope.
User or Machine, okay.
Also.
Also, Install.
Seven-Zip.
Ah, ne.
Nicht minus.
Punkt.
Äh, oder?
So.
Haha.
Nope.
Kann ich wirklich sagen, Location?
Minus L.
Jetzt machen wir mal irgendwie Test...
Ich mach jetzt einfach Test, weil es immer was hier hin...
Äh.
Warum ist eigentlich immer...
Ach Gott, Mann.
Microsoft, please.
Muss ich jetzt ernsthaft...
Users...
Max...
Äh.
Wo ist es?
Remove.
Okay.
Ähm.
Wie, der zeigt mir jetzt gar nicht mehr den Pfad da an, oder was?
Ja, das ist ja maximal useless.
Jetzt kann ich den Pfad auch nicht mehr aus dem Explorer kopieren.
Was Syntax war falsch.
Also es ist...
Es ist quasi...
Seven-Zip.
Ne. Hätte mich auch gewundert.
Also, Location.
L.
Ah ja, ich wollte hier den Ordner anlegen.
New.
Das ist so lahm auch, das neue Menü hier.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh, Software.
Okay, Software.
Okay.
Es ist im Prinzip egal.
Das kann keine Lokal...
Das kann keine Software managen ohne Rootrechte.
Win, get...
Without...
Admin.
Okay, also das ist anscheinend nicht so gedacht.
Na gut, dann installieren wir es.
Warum ich ohne Admin-Pakete verwalten will?
Weil ich nur für meine User-Sachen installieren will.
Das finde ich deutlich besser.
Ich meine, gut.
Unter den Jungs mache ich das auch systemweit.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber in dem Fall, gerade weil ich unter Windows mehrere Accounts habe,
finde ich das user-technisch deutlich angenehmer.
Ja.
Also ich jetzt beispielsweise, wenn ich auf den Streaming-Account nicht den ganzen Mist habe,
den ich auf einem anderen habe.
Seven-Zip.
Okay, das ging tatsächlich relativ einfach.
Okay, Search.
Also, wie ist Code?
Das muss es geben, oder?
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile im Store?
Nee, oder?
Microsoft hat es ja immer noch nicht geschafft, überhaupt ihren eigenen Krempel im Store zu packen.
Wie sucht man denn hier?
Ja.
Oh!
Tatsächlich!
Wie?
Die haben es mittlerweile geschafft, dass ihr ein Krempel im Store ist.
Wahnsinn.
Der Store nutzt inzwischen WinGet.
Ah, gute Entscheidung, ja.
Also muss ich jetzt...
Wisst ihr, das finde ich beispielsweise jetzt bei J oder irgendwelchen Arch Linux Package Manager ganz praktisch.
Da gibst du ein, was du suchst, und dann hat er hier eine Nummer davor.
Und wenn ich die Nummer eingebe, wenn es mehrdeutig ist,
wählt er das direkt aus.
So muss ich abbrechen, installen, machen und erstmal diesen Kram copy-pasten.
Ich meine, damit kann man leben.
Es gibt durchaus Schlimmeres.
Fazit?
Keine Ahnung.
Zweite Package, den ich installiere.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich relativ easy.
Finde ich gut.
So, wie macht man jetzt damit ein Update?
WinGet Update?
Wahrscheinlich?
Nee, WinGet...
Upgrade?
OneDrive?
Ich habe OneDrive überhaupt nicht.
Ist das wirklich installiert?
Also über einen Store?
Ah ja, gut, wenn es den Store benutzt.
Aber das ist was, was mich schon ein bisschen abschreckt.
Dass ich mit dem Package Manager Dinger verwalte, die ich nicht mit dem Package Manager installiert habe.
Gibt es jetzt den...
Was meinst du hier?
Was? TicTac?
Nö.
Was meinst du, ByteStrike?
Was davon?
TikTok?
Das ist TikTok.
Mit dem Start-Menü.
Achso, die Android.
Nee, Android gibt es, glaube ich, immer noch nicht.
Was? Der Clip?
ClipChamp?
Ne.
Der könnte ja fast von mir sein, bei dem Namen.
Der Clip...
Leute!
ClipChamp.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Guckt mal, wie schlecht, wie schlecht kann das sein.
Wie schlecht.
Es ist unmöglich, wie schlecht das ist.
Clipchamp? Und hier sagt er mir, ich hätte es angeblich installiert.
Wie schlecht kann es eigentlich sein?
Office.
Clipchamp.
Wie schlecht, Mann.
Ach, der installiert das erst, wenn ich draufklicke.
Es macht es nicht besser, Leute. Das macht es wirklich nicht besser.
Clip. Jetzt findet er es auch.
Uninstall.
Also.
Okay, Upgrade. Da können wir jetzt aber mal kurz gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Upgrade. Da gibt es auf jeden Fall minus minus all oder sowas.
Ja. Okay, das finde ich gut.
Und jetzt wird OneDrive installiert.
Nein, das ist nicht gut.
Also, wenn hier was pinned ist, erwarte ich, das ist installiert.
Ansonsten hat es da nicht zu stehen.
Und was hier gepinnt ist, erwarte ich auch, dass ich finde über die Suche.
Ansonsten sollte das hier unten stehen unter Vorschläge.
Aber nicht sich als installierte Anwendung ausgeben, wo ich gar nicht weiß, was da vorne installiert ist.
Das hat er einfach nicht zu stehen.
Guck mal.
Jetzt hat er Upgrade. Kann ich denn auch uninstall machen?
Uninstall OneDrive. Geht das auch?
Äh.
Ähm.
Gibt es da auch ein minus minus all?
OneDrive Sternchen?
Ne.
Also, sage ich ihm wahrscheinlich uninstall OneDrive.
Das da.
Ja.
Und das da.
Ne.
Wie mehrere Sachen aninstallen geht auch nicht.
Also, ein bisschen, bisschen müllig ist es schon.
So, und jetzt andere OneDrive deinstallieren.
Ja.
Ich erlaube diese App sich selbst zu...
Hä?
Okay.
Ich hinterfrage das nicht weiter.
So, guck mal.
Was haben wir noch Schönes?
Wingard Search.
Also, wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen, bisschen ausgefallenere Sachen, die ich aber brauche.
FFM-Pack.
Gibt's nicht.
Schrott. Unbrauchbar.
Warum gibt's kein FFM-Pack?
Must have.
Gibt es verschiedene Wingard Sources?
Package Request.
Wingard kann keine Zips installieren.
Das ist ja super.
Ja.
Können keine Zips installieren.
Support Installing Zip-Files.
No, God!
Was Zips sind implementiert?
Okay.
Wingard Upgrade Wingard.
Kann das sich selbst updaten?
Search Wingard.
Ne.
Version.
1, 2, 1, 1, 6, 0, 1.
Nee.
Ähm.
Tja, da haben wir schon die nächste Frage.
How to Upgrade Wingard?
Upgrade Wingard?
Self?
Irgendwie upgrade...
Upgrade Self oder sowas?
Einfach die APX von GitHub laden.
Oh, Mann.
Seriously?
Enable Wingard to upgrade itself?
Oh, WinCat.
Open. Open Feature Request.
Open.
Das ist mir deutlich zu sehr verheiratet mit dem
Windows Store, das Ganze.
Okay, also ZIP-Files sind ja
angeblich implementiert.
Specification P...
Nee.
Das ZIP ist anscheinend nicht implementiert.
Aber wir probieren das aus.
Sehe ich das
selbst? Wenn die jetzt updaten,
kann sich Winged nicht mehr selber
updaten, oder was? Also wenn
ich jetzt das Package
runterlade hier, ja?
Also mal angenommen, ich lade hier den...
Komm, wir suchen mal ZIP. ZIP.
Nö. ZIP steht hier nicht drin.
Also mal angenommen, ich lade mir diesen Krempel
von GitHub runter. Dann muss
ich immer, wenn ich meinen Package Manager
upgraden will, auf
GitHub und an APX runterladen, oder was?
Also überzeugt
mich...
Das wird nicht mit dem Windows Update
geupgradet, weil das ist ja...
Okay.
Also ja, wenn die es
releasen... Doch, du hast recht. Das wird mit
Windows geupgradet. Jaja, schon.
Aber der ZIP-Support ist in der
neuen GitHub-Version drauf.
Ich bräuchte jetzt quasi so ein
Prerelease-Channel, falls es sowas gibt.
Aber es kann sich ja aktuell auch
gar nicht selbst updaten, anscheinend.
Okay, also. Download.
Ja, mal ganz davon abgelehnt, es bringt mir nichts.
FFM-Pack ist ja nicht im Store drin.
Also vollkommen egal, ob das
Prerelease-Assets...
Wir updaten das mal.
Also. Was braucht man denn
davon? Das Mix...
MSX-Bundle?
Es erinnert mich ein bisschen an einen Apple-Installer,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Update. Moment, ich
update den Microsoft-Store? Habe ich das
gerade richtig gesehen?
Was genau möchte mir das jetzt sagen?
Was...
Was sagt mir das jetzt?
Ah, aber es ist die aktuelle. Okay,
es ist die aktuelle Version.
Ähm...
Wie?
Ach so, so zieht man sich neue...
Search
FFM-Pack.
Es ist an den Store gebunden wahrscheinlich, ja.
Okay, FFM-Pack
WinGetSource. Gibt es da vielleicht
ein extra Repo? Nein.
Ja, hier ist der Hacker-News-Hate
am Start. Ach so, geht
Uninstall eigentlich mittlerweile?
Das war ja das letzte Mal... Das letzte Mal
ging ja Uninstall noch nicht.
So dumm.
Alter, das zeigt ja alles an. Nicht nur
das, was ich mit dem Package-Manager installiert
habe. Leute, seid mir nicht
böse. Ich finde das Ding richtig schrottig bis jetzt.
So, jetzt muss ich hier erstmal
raussuchen, dass ich
ähm... Okay, wir sind
in PowerShell, also können wir sagen, Finster.
Das ist quasi das Windows-Grab.
So, Wischel Studio
Code. Hä?
Äh...
Ist...
Hau?
Weil Case-Sensitive?
Okay.
Ähm...
WinGet Uninstall
Microsoft
Wischel Studio Code.
Gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Okay, das Uninstall
funzt wenigstens halbwegs.
Install.
Okay, installieren wir wieder.
Gucken wir mal, was es noch gibt. Also, das erste ist
FFM-Pack gibt es schon mal nicht.
Also, das finde ich mit Scoop
alles bisher deutlich schöner.
Auch die Package-Auswahl.
So, weiter.
Weiter geht's.
Weiter geht's. Also, YouTube.dl.
Richtig, das habe ich auch. Das habe ich...
Das habe ich auch bei mir drin stehen.
Also, einmal suchen wir nach
YouTube.dl, dem alten, und dann suchen wir
nach, ähm, dem neuen.
YouTube...
Sieht nicht so aus, oder?
Also, das alte gibt's nicht.
Jaja, wir können nach dem neuen suchen.
Nope.
Ja. Es gibt ja fast nix
von dem, was ich haben will.
Lul.
Okay, weiter.
VLC.
Vengate Search VLC.
Den gibt es
wenigstens.
VLC.
Der Monika S. ist am Start.
7-Zip haben wir schon.
Huge Download Speed.
Okay, VLC.
Das hätte ich jetzt aber auch erwartet.
So, jetzt machen wir gleich...
Ja, yes. Jetzt bauen wir gleich
ein paar etwas speziellere Varianten.
Das ist... Choose My Name.
Das ist der Windows Store.
Dahinter anscheinend, so wie es aussieht.
Steam. Steam. Das ist eine gute...
Steam und Firefox. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Search.
Firefox.
Kann man nur über Edge installieren? Keine Ahnung.
Vingate Install.
Firefox Browser.
Äh. Okay.
Dass da so viele Sachen doppelt
drin sind?
Okay, Firefox ist drin.
Nice.
Firefox Funst. Sehr schön.
Ähm, ich will ja nur mal gucken, was...
Steam kann ich gucken.
Aber Steam muss man darüber nicht installieren.
Steam updatet sich selbst und möchte sich auch
weiterhin selbst updaten.
Ja, aber Steam gibt es.
Steam gäbe es.
Also...
Wir machen jetzt mal, aber wie gesagt,
ein paar bisschen ausgefallene
Sachen.
IPerf.
Nope. War klar.
War klar.
Also Sachen, die ich wirklich brauchen würde.
Node.js.
Open.js. Node.js.
Okay, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Okay. Schau, dass wir
sehen, wo es herkommt.
Da muss man schon viel zu viel tippen.
ID. Docker. Docker können wir auch
gucken. Von wo zieht er das? Node.js.
Okay, das ist schon mal gut.
Das wird es geben.
Okay. Docker für Windows.
Paints.champ. Wer macht denn so?
So was.
Ja, gibt es.
Nicht Rust. Rust
Up braucht man ja.
Nope. Und Rust?
Rust gibt es, aber
Rust Up gibt es nicht.
Das heißt, man kann nichts nachinstallieren.
Ja, okay. Immerhin.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Trusted RU.
Crypto Arm Ghost.
Das klingt so, als braucht man das.
Gekommen.
Jetzt.
Eine andere Sache.
WinDirStat verwende ich ganz gerne.
Für Windows. Ah, das ist drauf. Das finde ich gut.
Install.
WinDirStat.
Eigentlich reicht es, wenn ich gucke.
Ich muss diesen ganzen Krempel nicht installieren.
Die sollten unbedingt einen Approved-Status
einführen. Das ist ja gerade das Gute
an den Windows, ähm, äh, an den Linux
Package Repos.
Doch, ich muss die ID eingeben, sonst weiß er nicht,
was er nehmen soll. Außer es gibt es nur einfach.
Okay.
Das ist auch das Richtige, so wie es aussieht, ja.
Ja, das passt.
Da sieht man, wo welche Ordner, wie belegt sind.
Python und Pip, das können wir gleich mal gucken, ja.
Ich denke mal, die meisten Programmiersprachen.
EP, was? JPEG View?
Das, überhaupt, was ist das?
Ich meine, JPEG kann Windows auch so?
Mailwasher Pro. Klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja.
Ja.
Ah, SQLite Browser.
Da bin ich jetzt mal natürlich nicht.
Ne.
Ah, das ist halt blöd. Prozessexplorer.
Äh, Prozessexplorer oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich danach suchen soll.
Der ist bestimmt drin. Ich weiß so nicht, nach was ich suchen muss.
Nicht Prozessecker. Prozessexplorer.
Nach SUS Internals. Das ist eine gute.
Monika.
Das ist, das, die können...
nicht monka s schreiben nee das ist sowas wie kürzel oder so heißt das okay was auch immer
das sein soll gibt es nicht prozessexplorer kann er die twitch app keine ahnung twitter ist doch
krepp ja aber ich weiß nicht ob der pipp dabei ist ist der pipp dabei man weiß es nicht was es
sein soll ich meine dass es da auch keine description gibt ja so richtig foto frame
ok wichtig hack von hack von das ist wichtig
oh leute rogers ganz wichtig das ist das ist eigentlich das essentiellste überhaupt
die jetbrains sachen gibt es die habe ich gerade schon gesehen aber mich würde die
jetbrains toolbox installieren moment no von wo lädt er das runter das finde ich gut dass
man sich das anzeigen lassen kann geht's ab so okay das ist richtig aber dass der
für alles adminrechte braucht bin ich doof ich meine fonds installation okay aber es
war schön wenn es die option gäbe das nicht global zu installieren
so und kann ich jetzt hack von hack von einstellen settings color schemes ja
wo stellt man hier appearance stellt man hier um 7 es ist schon viel besser fonds und gab es da
irgendwo
gel das ist immer so ein bisschen versteckt ich finde dass ich finde das immer nicht hack
ich will hack bester von jawohl save online able to find a contacted Syrian
her
tech
ателя
wiroria
zahlers das sieht das sieht auch sehr nach hacker von aus alles klar da ich
viel besser wenn get search ich war ich habe noch ein paar sachen nicht aus
blieb ausprobieren ob es auf sie gibt
audacity gibt es okay das muss ich jetzt nicht installieren das glaube ich auch
so wim neowim gibt es okay das schon mal gut
bin jetzt install leute wem oder neowim es ist egal zum testen ist schon in
ordnung obs können wir tatsächlich suchen im ex
dnn geben nein geht ich will kein fucking geben
ich will den komandozeilen wim 3d
im
ist pock aber das gibt es hier glaube ich nicht oder wim 3d ist ist ist
wirklich okay wenn wir unser windows willst du wahrscheinlich eher nicht aha
es geht schon mal nicht interaktiv nice der wim installer wirkt auch top modern
ok da war neowim geht refresh end wenn gibt man das einfach so im terminal
ein java java gibt es bestimmt
refresh end oder muss ich terminal wirklich zu machen
zack wo ist die musik terminal neowim endwim ah exzellent nur für echte hacker gibt es tmax für
für echte hacker gibt es tmax für echte hacker gibt es tmax für
windows eigentlich mehr als noch nie nein jetzt auch gewundert gibt es die max
windows so ich glaube jetzt habe also die softwareauswahl ist naja sag mal so
so zu 50 prozent da könnte man könnte man denke ich sagen
ach so wie sieht es mit sachen wie go oder so aus habe ich das richtig gemacht
habe ich das richtig gemacht habe ich das richtig gemacht habe ich das richtig gemacht
habe ich das richtig gemacht Handel
Tweet
handshake
zeppelin
also ich hätte keine ahnung dass es unter windows geht wenn ich das mache
ich automatisch kontroll w ist du musst aufpassen kontroll w ist auch tab
schließen wenn du irgendwo über den remote desktop im browser drauf bist
machst und tab damit so hat wind das gucken wir jetzt gleich wir gucken
ob man es gut oder zog über wind installieren kann was jetzt guckt jetzt
jetzt guckt erstmal irgendeiner aus dem google in indischen google support bei
mir auf dem rechner wenn ich das installiert nein das natürlich nicht
drauf und das ist theoretisch theoretisch nur dass nur dass nur das
gui ist drauf naja das bringt mir jetzt das bringt mir nicht so viel was mein
thema ich sollte gucken ob es libro office gibt das gibt es bestimmt banana
cake pop ist das nicht ist das nicht der dieser
kritik der der
kraft ql client von den einen typen was only office anscheinend auch der monika
es discord ist eine gute frage ja discord gibt es auch das finde ich ganz
gut sus ide jetbrains die jetbrains toolbox
wäre gut jetbrains toolbox
ok das ist cool dass sie das drauf haben weil das ist ja quasi der jetbrains
package manager gibt es gesudow was ist denn gesudow für windows oder obs notepad
plus plus ja moment gucke ich gleich der muss jetzt erst mal java zeug
installieren toolbox ja habe ich schon gesucht schokolade schokolade dienst gibt
es nicht continue ich habe schon gesucht schokolade dienst gibt es nicht continue
ich habe schon gesucht schokolade dienst gibt es nicht continue
nein nein nein nein ja gut jetzt könnte ich hier mal ein krempe nach installieren
ja kann ich sagen ja install rider sonstwas das finde ich gut was sollte
ich jetzt noch gucken moment search e-sudo gibt es der geradoc obs der das
kann ich machen eklips e-git
eklips e-git
ja aber gibt es anscheinend auch sätgen aber weißt ja nicht cared
wie okay wenn man kann es ja man kann es ja mal ausprobieren
obs obs aladdin bis outs studio gibt es ja das ist ziemlich glocke dass es das
gibt das ist nice weih yard gute frage
weih yard gute frage
ja doch gibt es immer auf du brauchst kein putin mehr erst das haarklein ist
mittlerweile windows eingebaut ms store source ist zu pepega dass es ordentlich
funktioniert türk wird das hatte ich jahre schon nicht mehr drauf gibt's also
okay ich würde sagen die software auswahl ist doch vielleicht sogar 70
prozent ich habe jetzt paar dinge halt gesucht
nicht gefunden ja also ich glaube ich leute haben wir gefunden aber einfach
ein paar kammer beispielsweise nicht gefunden den sq lite browser haben wir
nicht gefunden youtube download haben wir nicht gefunden
ipad aber nicht gefunden kobold gibt kein kobold was super f4 was ist
denn super f4 was ist super f4 kann man danach googeln
kills 4
programmen control a das ist quasi x kill bzw
kill ex für unter linux ok das steht ja aber die software auswahl ist durchaus
okay also ich finde das handling ein bisschen ja gewöhnungsbedürftig dass es
keine zips files handeln kann ist doof dass es nur mit admin funktioniert ist
doof software also vorteile sind eindeutig software-auswahl die ist okay
und das ist halt mit windows abortmitteln
also dass es halt mit windows mitgeliefert wird ein gui hat das nicht
das finde ich aber auch nicht schlecht package manager ist package manager in
dem fall ist mir lieber über romantline was kann man jetzt settings was passiert
aha erst mal will studio code launchen poggers auto update intervall okay geht
auch alles klar gibt es alternative package quellen anscheinend nicht aber
man kann man kann wohl aber ich habe jetzt nichts gefunden
package repos sources community repos gibt's das gucken wir uns doch gleich
mal an heißt du maximilian ja heiß ich warum
willst du es nicht sagen
das wissen oder und wie installiert das community repo oder ist das das repo was
schon vorinstalliert ist also ist das hier quasi das wenn hier win jetzt steht
wahrscheinlich oder unter manifests ffm pf
ok das ist die software hier also das heißt dass ich kann darüber raus
ok
Okay, Git. Wir müssen Git installieren.
Search Git.
Okay, das mache ich jetzt nicht hier drüber.
Weil ganz ehrlich,
dann würde ich mir einen WSL draufhauen.
Weil ich dachte mir,
man könnte
das ja mal klonen.
Man könnte das ja mal
klonen und dann einfach zählen.
Ah, ja, ja.
Und dann mal zählen,
wie viel Software eigentlich da drin ist.
Git.git.
Ich will das aber nicht unter Windows machen, Leute.
Wir starten mal kurz
die Poggers vor M.
Wir klonen uns
das Git-Repo von WinGet
und dann zählen wir mal, wie viel Software da drin ist.
Was mit Shell?
Hä?
Jetzt hopp.
WinGet
Community
Repo.
So.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
wie viel.
Was da drin ist.
Also.
Ja, gib ihm.
So, also, wo sind die Dinger?
WinGet Manifests.
Irgendwie so.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
FD?
Depth?
Find?
Da?
Depth 1?
Max Depth 1?
Äh, gleich.
Ach.
Ach, okay.
Ja, ist gut, ist gut.
So.
Was?
Ach so, ich muss erst mal.
Wait a minute.
Hm, wie finde ich denn jetzt, wie kann ich das jetzt am besten zählen?
Google.
Google, find.
Also, ich muss ihm sagen, ein, ein Verzeichnis
nach unten.
Oder gleich?
Wir, wir fragen.
Ach, man muss einen Namen angeben, oder was?
Hier ein Sternchen geht anscheinend.
Okay, gut.
Das ist genau das, was ich haben will.
Es ist nicht ganz richtig, weil die Zahlen sind noch mit,
die einzelnen Verzeichnisse sind noch mit drinne.
WC, ups.
2400.
Nur?
Die wenig, oder?
Nö.
Scheint, nö.
2400.
Wie viel ist, wie viel ist im Ubuntu-Repo drinne, Packages?
Ubuntu-Repo-Package-Count.
Ne, MinDepth 2 brauche ich nicht.
Achso, habe ich doch. Passt doch.
Er gibt schon Sinn.
Also, es ist ein bisschen verkehrt,
weil er diese, also sind irgendwie 24,
24 Verzeichnisse
zu viel?
Achso, ja das könnte ich auch mal. Stimmt.
So.
Ne, haha, könnte ich nicht.
Das dachte ich mir.
Dann macht er noch mehr.
System Packages, ja und?
Interessiert mich jetzt einfach nur mal im Vergleich.
50.000.
Achso ist das.
Achso, ne.
Ah, ok, guck mal.
Wenn einer noch mehr Software hat,
dann steht es da,
steht es unten drunter.
Also sind im besten Fall
5000,
wobei da jetzt
alles doppelt ist noch.
Also ziehen wir mal ab, sagen wir mal
ungefähr 5000.
Sagen wir mal ungefähr 5000.
Wenn überhaupt.
Naja,
für das, dass die erst angefangen, wobei
die haben nicht erst angefangen, oder?
Den Kram gibt es schon eine ganze Weile.
Es ist nicht minus, es ist nicht minus
26, das stimmt nicht.
Weil, guck mal.
Leute, die
mehrere Sachen haben, hier zum Beispiel
OBS
Patent Lobster, alles klar.
OBS taucht hier jetzt zum Beispiel
einmal zu viel auf.
Also alles, was mehr als ein Projekt hat,
taucht einmal zu viel auf.
Laut
Wininstall gibt es
3500, ja.
Ja,
kann durchaus sein.
Es ist jetzt aber nicht so mega viel,
ehrlich gesagt.
Versus irgendwie 60.000 oder so
in dem Ubuntu Repo.
Stimmt, wir haben schon vor Jahren uns
Winged
angeguckt.
Wie viele
Arch User Repos gibt es eigentlich
insgesamt mittlerweile, Packages?
Ähm.
Okay, alleine Arch User
Repos gibt es
86.000, äh
83.838.
Was eine Zahl, Leute.
Haben die sich,
haben die sich irgendwas gedacht, hier?
Guck mal hier, die Zahl ist doch geil.
83838.
Also da kann Winged, da kann
Winged tatsächlich dagegen einpacken.
Und das sind ja nur die Zusatz,
also die zusätzlichen Repos.
Pacman hat ja auch
die System Packages schon.
Wie viele Packages hat Scoop?
Das können wir gleich mal kurz gucken.
Erst mal kurz
Package Updates machen, äh, nicht
Package Updates, äh, Repos aktualisieren.
Weiß nicht, ob man
das da überhaupt rausbekommt. Lass mal kurz
gucken. Ähm.
Kann man sowas machen wie List?
Ne, List.
Alias?
Gute Frage.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man da, Search?
Search und dann irgendwie
Sternchen oder so vielleicht?
Oh Leute, jetzt hab ich's geprickt.
Jetzt hab ich's geprickt.
Das war, das war zu viel.
Kann Windows sowas?
Hackle.txt
Mal kurz zwischenspeichern.
Ah, so halbwegs.
Weniger?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das alle sind.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Weniger, aber anscheinend mehr von dem, was ich verwende.
Moment.
Ist gar nicht alles, oder?
Buckets? Irgendwo da.
Da war ein Waifu Package.
Nice.
Das ist genau das Richtige für den Chat.
Wo ist das, wo ist das Waifu Package?
Ah.
Waifu2x
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich mich traue,
das zu suchen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, Upscaling für Anime
ist das.
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen.
Also im Main Repo sind schon
1000 drinne.
Also im Main Repo sind 1000 drinne
ungefähr.
So, im Extras Repo
sind auch 1000 drinne.
Ne, 1500.
Ja, das kommt ungefähr hin, was wir ausgerechnet haben.
3000 Packages. Gut.
Scoopert weniger, aber ehrlich gesagt
finde ich dort eher das, was ich
haben will.
Es gibt auch Java Games und Extras
Repos.
Also ist wahrscheinlich die beste Variante,
beides zu verwenden, Leute.
Wobei ich das Handling
das Handling
von Winged
ein bisschen painstamp
finde.
Na, Repo Package Anzahl ist schon wichtig.
Wichtige Größe für Package Manager.
Weil der Package Manager selbst
kann ja noch so geil sein,
wenn es darüber nichts zum installieren gibt,
dann kann man auch mal
knicken.
Nee, Shokum habe ich früher mal verwendet.
Mochte ich nie wirklich.
Wir schauen mal, wie viel da drinne ist.
Ja, ja, I understand.
Guck mal, da sind es 9205.
Hat noch ein bisschen Vorsprung.
Gucken wir mal, ob es dort
FFM Pack
gäbe.
Gibt es FFM Pack, kein Problem.
Auch die ordentlichen fast
wie die Builds.
Wisst ihr, ich predikte, was als nächstes
passiert, ja. Es gibt
ja manche Leute, die verwenden alle 3.
Und jetzt kommt irgendwann einer
auf die Idee und macht ein Meta Package
Manager. Ein Package
Manager für Package Manager.
Und mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn es das schon gibt.
Ich will jetzt nicht auf GitHub suchen,
weil ich fürchte, das gibt es schon.
Ein Meta Package Manager,
der einfach alle 3 unter einer
Oberfläche vereint.
Package Manager as a Service, pass.
Wobei, das ist schon vorher vorbelegt.
Das ist ja eigentlich
Plattform as a Service.
Warum gibt es eigentlich nicht Service as a Service
so als Wildcard?
Das ist rekursiv Service as a Service.
Endlosschleife.
Ja, ja, theoretisch.
Theoretisch schon.
Ja, eigentlich ist es Software as a Service, aber
ja, könnte man machen.
Also,
das Schwierige daran wäre halt, dass du
die Eigenheiten von allen
Package Manager handeln musst.
Ja, man müsste theoretisch alle 3
verwenden. Es gibt
MPM.
Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Ich kenne,
ich kenne
MPM.
MPM ist das ein
Meta Package Manager.
MPM Meta Package Manager.
Ist das für Windows?
Ach nee, das ist, ähm,
ein Meta Package Manager.
Oh Gott, nein!
Nooo, Gott!
Kann er WinGet?
Was?
Okay, der kann
kein WinGet und Scoop bisher.
Meta
Package Manager ist
Wahnsinn. Also,
halten wir mal fest,
die beste Variante ist, ganz
einfach, wir verwenden
Windows mit dem absoluten Mindesten,
was wir unter Windows brauchen,
und den Rest verwenden wir einfach weiter
in einer ordentlich
eingerichteten Linux-VM
und alles ist gut.
Sehe ich richtig, oder?
Arch Linux, by the way.
Also, das einzig ordentlich eingerichtete
Linux, was ich gelten lasse, ist Arch Linux.
GNU! Sorry,
sorry, Arch GNU
GNU, GNU Linux.
Das sagt doch niemand, oder?
Das habe ich noch nie gehört, dass das
jemand sagt.
Steht GNU überhaupt irgendwo
auf der Arch-Seite?
Okay, die
Compiler und so, alles klar.
Arch in WSL2.
Wifetime.
So, das lösche ich mal wieder, WinGet.
Das Repo, das ist schon viel zu groß.
Und,
jaja, Proceed.
Und, ich lösche das Windows
ISO wieder.
Das frisst mir ein...
Achso, das hängt in der
RAM drinne.
Gachi-Bus.
Steckt noch im Laufwerk.
Disconnect.
Zack.
Warum haben wir ein
Ultralativ-
Bild?
Ach, das ist von den YouTube-Networks,
was er, wo er gezeigt hat, wer mit wem
was zu tun hat. Das wollten wir uns in groß angucken.
Jetzt, jetzt weiß ich's wieder.
So, Platz checken ist wieder ein bisschen...
Ja, okay, 11,11,1 G.
Alles klar. Tja, also die anderen
Package-Manager muss ich, kann ich jetzt nicht mehr ausprobieren.
Heute, es ist 22 Uhr, ich muss gleich ins Bett.
Also, ich muss sagen, WinGet ist
brauchbar, aber, also die Bedienung
ist...
eh weiß ich, Microsoft und Kommandozeilen
Tools...
Was? Xterm?
Wo? Da?
Ne.
Kannst du pennen, wenn's so warm ist? Ja, ich mach die Klimaanlage an.
Auf dem Windows-Desktop? Xterm.
Achso, ne. Das ist...
Das war mal ein Versuch...
WSL...
Das kann ich runterschmeißen.
Das war mal ein Versuch WSL
mit X unter Windows
zu betreiben. Haben wir mal ausprobiert.
Das ging nicht gut.
Der Desktop ist
massive nice.
Der Desktop ist ein ganz normaler Ordner
wie alles andere auch.
Mit WSL 2 unter Windows 11
ist es wohl eingebaut, ja.
...
Hast du von der
Goodwill Ransomware gehört?
Ne.
Was macht die?
Ransomware zwingt Opfer für Bedürftige
zu spenden.
So ganz uneigennützig
werden sie das wahrscheinlich aber trotzdem
nicht gemacht haben.
Ansonsten,
wenn das irgendwie selbstlos...
...
Hijacked Virtual Machines, ja.
Powerful Servers.
Wow.
Normalerweise
sind wir hier so bei
1,5 Millionen
Requests die Sekunde.
So, und dann waren wir mal
einfach mal kurz bei 26 Millionen
Requests die Sekunde.
Na geht was.
Cloudflash schreibt da ja auch nur drüber,
weil sie wieder erzählen können. Guckt mal her,
wie geil wir das abgewehrt haben.
HTTPS Attacks, okay.
Nicht HTTPS,
über HTTPS, also irgendwelche
HTTPS-Services.
In 30 Sekunden
mehr als
212 Millionen HTTPS-Requests.
Top Count Countries,
okay. Indonesien,
USA, Brasilien
und Russland.
3% über Tor.
Ja gut, das hat ja für Tor allein schon
gereicht, dass es wahrscheinlich wieder nicht richtig
benutzbar war.
Weil bandbreitentechnisch
ist es mit Bator jetzt ja nicht so weit her.
Network Sources, OVH.
Das ist da, wo das
RZ abgebrannt ist, glaube ich.
Die indonesische Telekom.
iBoss
und Libyan
iYill.
Ja, was da los war, weiß man nicht. Außer, dass es
26 Millionen Requests die Sekunde gab.
Tot, net, tot.
U-Block.
Ich habe das ein bisschen anders
konfiguriert. Ich habe...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich
Custom-Blocklisten drin habe.
Bisschen was rumgestellt habe ich, ja.
Aber größtenteils Standard.
Werder Internet und Geld
für Cloudflare natürlich.
Ja.
Vor ein paar Tagen war überall
500er-Fehlermeldung.
Vielleicht hat es damit was zu tun, keine Ahnung.
Je nachdem, was du
öffnen wolltest, kann das tatsächlich sein.
Was macht eigentlich die Cloudflare-Aktie?
Haben die... Sind die überhaupt eine Aktie?
Ja.
Erstmal auf dicke Hose gemacht. Achso, ne.
Aber insgesamt ist Cloudflare halt immer noch.
Weil, wie alles dieses Jahr.
Es ist dieses Jahr einfach alles so abfuck, was das angeht.
Was, GitLab? GitLab ist eine...
Wirklich?
Keck Wait, tatsächlich.
Ja, dieses Jahr ist äußerst Painschamp.
Mein GitHub kann es ja schlecht geben, das ist ja Microsoft.
Wie sieht es bei Microsoft so aus?
Also man muss sagen,
also eins muss man Microsoft ja mal echt lassen, gell?
Seit der neue Chef
übernommen hat und Ball mal weg ist,
ist das Ding einfach nur
durch die Decke gegangen.
Also der macht schon was richtig.
Wie sieht's...
Egal, ich gucke jetzt nicht weiter.
Leute, ich muss jetzt pennen.
Bad Getime.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen, genau.
Wir machen jetzt
berühmtes Stream beenden
Any%
Haha.
Wie man das von mir kennt.
Du bekommst deinen Desktop nicht so ordentlich hin wie ich.
Ich geb zu, das ist auch schwer.
Da kann ich dir jetzt keine Tipps auf die Stelle geben.
Das braucht schon ein bisschen Übung.
Ja, du schon, ich geb 22 U-Pen.
Okay, Leute, also.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.